Sweden and Finland are joining NATO
which is this big military Alliance from
all the European countries who don't
like Russia
NATO is one of the major reasons why
Russia invaded Ukraine in the first
place Russia invaded Ukraine and tried
to make it really costly on Western
Nations so that they would fracture and
instead it totally backfired NATO has
come together in a new way it has new
purpose and now Finland and Sweden are
joining and now look Finland has created
this new border with Russia and NATO
that didn't exist before but now it does
these great Washington Post Maps show
you just how Russia is becoming isolated
and surrounded by NATO exactly the thing
that Vladimir Putin didn't want to
happen big backfire